if this Market existed if eBay was
around when I was 15 years old I would
have never graduated high school
my mom to this day thanks God that eBay
came out after I was done she is
completely convinced and she's right
that I wouldn't have graduated Junior
High School they would have been a wrap
I was doing it anyway in the old world
literally got my car and the first thing
I would do after school instead of going
like hanging out with friends or girls
would go to Toys R Us would go to the
dollar store like a [__] machine all
to sell on the weekend three weeks from
now at a flea market or a sports card
and collectible show if I had [__]
eBay
[__]